[Music]
today's question comes from kim in
arizona she says my husband wants us to
help his daughter purchase her
grandmother's home for sixty thousand
dollars his motivation for doing this is
he wants her to move close to where we
live
she was just let go from a job for
tardiness and has fourteen thousand
dollars in debt she just got back from
an expensive vacation and doesn't even
have enough for the down payment on this
house how can i convince him this is a
very bad idea
wow the art of persuasion that's it's a
difficult one i don't know that you can
convince him
of anything it sounds like he's made up
his mind that his daughter needs to have
this house regardless of her financial
situation
which is a bad place to be so uh kim
knows this is a bad idea but she's
asking how do i get him on board with
the fact that this is not the time for
her to purchase this house
there is a few times in my life i have
been an enabler
but a whole bunch of times in my life
doing financial coaching i have run into
people who are enablers whether they're
enabling someone that's an addict or
they're enabling other bad behaviors
enablers which your husband is kim
is
are the nicest
people
that want to help
they're very sweet people if you're an
enabler i know this about you you're a
kind
gentle compassionate
you're not a grouchy person you're a
sweet person
because enablers always are they and
they always feel like they want to help
and he wants his daughter close to him
that's sweet
and he wants to help his little daughter
and he's helped her a lot over the years
to the point that she's basically
useless
he's helped her so much that she has no
character she can't seem to show up at
work on time
she's a grown-up who can't even scrape
together the money for this i mean
you know he's
created a mess
and the thing the kim the only thing
i've ever been able to do with enablers
because they are convinced that they're
helping
and they are
helping people do the wrong things
uh and they're the sweetest people is i
just tell them i just say you know
you're so sweet
you need to realize though that when you
think you're helping
you're actually hurting
so honey i i don't think you should
bring harm to your daughter
i think you should love her enough to
not bring harm to her
and to participate in her craziness
to participate in her irresponsibility
and encourage it by financing it
is bringing harm to her
she needs to learn to keep a job by
showing up on time get her freaking work
done
and the fact that she can't do that is
because you've done this with her her
whole life because you've helped her so
much that she has no character
she has no bones
inside of her character
and so honey you're not helping you're
hurting
you're bringing harm to her
because you're not doing anything except
she's not going to get better because
you did this
um now the goal is for her to live
closer to them and the grandmother and
the grandmother's home is in the deal
too so there's also some sentimental
value here emotion and sentimental value
so here's what we could do
that i think would be good for his
daughter
is to say um
okay here's what we're going to do
if you do these three things
i'm going to help you
but i'm not going to do them for you
unless you do these three things
one is you get four jobs and you start
working 60 hours to 80 hours a week
you will not die from hard work
just before you die from hard work you
pass out so you will not die from hard
work you're going to be okay that's
science it's it's science yeah and uh
it's brain science and so
uh you're going to be okay i want you
and number one number two you're going
to go through financial peace university
and you're going to graduate in a week
you're going to binge watch the videos
and you're going to go through them and
we're going to discuss them together
and number three with all the money that
you're making you're going to save all
of it you're going to spend none of it
on stupid butt stuff because you need to
come up with a down payment really
really quick and if you do that for 60
days i'll help you get this house
but if you don't do that i'm not going
to help you get this house
and so what you're doing there is you're
encouraging her and you know i'll be mad
one more i'll pay off half of your debt
your 14 000 debt after you pay off the
first half
get some space
i'll match you you put a thousand on it
i'll put a thousand on it you put two
thousand on it i'll put two thousand
until it's gone that gets where the
fourteen thousand dollars worth of debt
and then then we'll help you get
grandma's house but um but she's not
gonna be able to keep grandma's house
she's gonna lose grandma's house she's
gonna get foreclosed on if you go into
it this way
so the only thing i've ever been able
the only way i've ever been able to get
an enabler to stop enabling is to
convince them that they're actually
bringing harm because an enabler can't
stand the idea that they would be
hurting someone because they're sweet
people
and if i can finally convince them that
they're causing harm rather than helping
that their version of help is actually
harmful
then um that's that's the deal sometimes
kicking someone's butt is the best thing
you can do for them absolutely
absolutely especially if it's you know
it's moms and dads with grown kids in
their basement
i mean um
listen an eagle that doesn't leave the
nest eventually is known as a turkey and
so you you know you've got to help them
leave
for their sake
you're not helping them you're hurting
them you're bringing you've got a 36
year old in your basement you've brought
them harm they're emotionally stunted in
their growth
their ability to function in the culture
is stunted because you've you've brought
them harm and you thought you were
helping providing that you're still
continuing to do their laundry
you know and it's just and that's not
well that's tough love you're just tough
it's not tough love honey that's love
it's it's love to allow people to live
out their best life create a sustainable
situation with dignity that's empowering
that's love that's real love yeah
and you know toxic love is i'm gonna
keep you around so i feel better
and let me continue your misbehavior
that's enable that's enabler language
what about what about this plan what if
she could rent grandma's home
since she's broke and eventually it can
be hers well depends on who she's
renting it from i don't know the
ownership level we don't have that
information that if dad has to buy it
and rent it to her that's about it she's
not going to pay the payment and then
he's not going to throw her out
because now we're we're just expecting
your daughter that's awkward well we
just it is awkward but you're also
setting her up to lose
because she knows she's not going to pay
the payment she knows he's a pushover
an enabler
same thing and yeah so she she knows
this and so she knows exactly where they
stand
so no you can't you can't put her in
there with him as the backstop
because him backstopping her has been
the issue but but you know the truth is
kim
your husband is a kind nice man he
really is a good person
he's sweet he really is a sweet person
and i'm not making fun i'm not being
sarcastic i really do think he is
he has just defined
the word help
wrong his definition of help
is not accurate
you're not helping your harming when you
give a drunk a drink you didn't help the
drunk
you feel better because you feel like
you did something and you thought you
were nice and you didn't create conflict
but you didn't help you brought harm
when a drunk continues
to be enough to be a drunk because you
helped that's the definition of harm
toxic generosity that's what it is it's
a definition of harm